♪ ♪
>> Tucker: SO SUDDENLY THE
SAME KIND OF NIHILISM YOU'RE
SEEING IN OUR FOREIGN POLICY, WE
DON'T CARE WHAT HAPPENS, YOU'RE
SEEING APPLY TO OUR DOMESTIC
POLICY AND EVEN TO QUESTIONS OF
SCIENCE.
SO THE PEOPLE IN CHARGE OF
TELLING OF THE BIOLOGICAL SEX
ISN'T REAL AND IF YOU DISAGREE,
YOU'RE A RACIST.
FOR A LOT OF LIFELONG DEMOCRATS
THIS IS BEWILDERING.
THEY DIDN'T SIGN UP FOR THIS.
COLIN WRIGHT HAS BEEN A DEMOCRAT
ALL HIS LIFE, DIDN'T SIGN UP FOR
THIS.
SO A YEAR AGO HE CAME UP WITH A
CARTOON TO ILLUSTRATE WHAT HE
THOUGHT WAS GOING ON.
HE HASN'T CHANGED BUT THE PEOPLE
WHO WERE PRESENT HIM IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAVE BECOME
VERY UNREASONABLE.
ELON MUSK AGREES, HE JUST SHARED
THIS CARTOON ON TWITTER.
IN A "WALL STREET JOURNAL" OP-ED
HE ASKED POINT HE MADE THE
CARTOON TO KIND OF SORT OUT HOW
HE FEELS IS A LIFELONG DEMOCRAT.
COLIN WRIGHT IS AN EVOLUTIONARY
BIOLOGIST AND WE ARE HAPPY TO
HAVE HIM JOIN US TONIGHT.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
YOU CAN DESCRIBE THIS BETTER
THAN I CAN PARAPHRASE.
WHY DID YOU DRAW THIS CARTOON AT
WHAT DOES IT MEAN?
>> YEAH, SO I DREW THIS CARTOON
IN BED ONE NIGHT IN MY PAJAMAS
BECAUSE I HAD THIS INCREASING
FEELING OF ALIENATION FROM, YOU
KNOW, THE POLITICAL LEFT, ON A
LOT OF CORE VALUES THAT I FELT
WERE CENTRAL TO WHO I WAS AS A
VOTER, SO ON ISSUES SUCH AS
FREE SPEECH, FOR INSTANCE, THAT
I THINK THE LEFT HELD AS BEING
SACROSANCT FOR MUCH OF ITS
HISTORY, YOU KNOW, IT'S BEEN --
THESE VALUES OF FREE SPEECH WERE
GENERALLY HELD TO BE THESE CORE
VALUES IN ORDER TO UPHOLD
FREE SPEECH, TO SPEAK TRUTH TO
POWER AND IT'S BEING
INCREASINGLY VIEWED AS SORT
OF --
>> Tucker: IS ON ACCEPTABLE.
PEOPLE ARE BEING CALLED RACIST
FOR WANTING FREE SPEECH.
YOU KEEP HEARING THAT.
IS THAT -- WHEN YOU SIGNED UP AS
A LIBERAL OR DEMOCRAT OR YOU
THOUGHT THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
WERE PRESENTED YOU, EVEN FIVE
YEARS AGO, WOULD HAVE BEEN
PLAUSIBLE THAT SOMEBODY AT MSNBC
WOULD SAY YOU'RE RACIST IF YOU
WANT FREE SPEECH?
>> WELL, NO, IT'S BEING
INCREASINGLY VIEWED AS HOSTILE
TO THE GOVERNMENT, IT'S BEING
HOSTILE TO -- YOU KNOW, THESE
IDEAS THAT WE HAVE OF
FREE SPEECH, AND ON ISSUES SUCH
AS RACISM, FOR INSTANCE, WHERE
THE PREVIOUS VALUES THAT WE HAD
OF JUDGING PEOPLE BY THE CONTENT
OF THEIR CHARACTER, FOR
INSTANCE, RATHER THAN BY, YOU
KNOW, THE COLOR OF THEIR SKIN.
THIS HAS BEEN REPLACED BY THESE
SORT OF IDENTITY POLITICS AND
EQUITY INITIATIVES THAT ARE
REALLY VALUING GROUP IDENTITY
OVER INDIVIDUAL RIGHTS, AND THEN
ON THE ISSUES OF WOMEN'S RIGHTS,
FOR INSTANCE, WE SEE -- YOU
KNOW, RIGHT HAS NOT ALWAYS BEEN
THE BEST ARE CONSISTENT ON THESE
ISSUES, BUT AT LEAST THE RIGHT
KNOWS WHAT A WOMAN IS.
YOU KNOW, AN ADULT HUMAN FEMALE.
AND I WOULD SAY THAT AS A
BIOLOGIST, SO I SAY THAT WITH
CERTAINTY.
THE LEFT, ON THE OTHER HAND,
THEY CAN'T EVEN TELL YOU WHAT A
WOMAN IS, SO THEY CAN EVEN
REALLY PRETEND TO UNDERSTAND OR
TO PROTECT WOMEN'S RIGHTS.
THIS IS KIND OF MY GROWING
FEELING OF BEING DISAFFECTED
FROM THE LEFT ON THESE MANY
ISSUES AND I THINK A LOT OF
AMERICANS AND PEOPLE ABROAD FEEL
THE SAME WAY.
>> Tucker: I AGREE.
PEOPLE ABROAD, IT'S NOT JUST
THIS COUNTRY.
THE WORLD TAKES ITS CUES FROM
US, THE WEST DOES.
IF YOU LIKE THE CONVERSATION, WE
HAD A LONG CONVE